what is going on there reject nation
greg here today john is out of
commission right now for a few days he's
uh getting surgery some of you guys
noticed that too he's missing tooth
there he's getting some work done gonna
come back here looking perfect in the
meantime it's me me holding down the
fort i literally just got done 20
minutes ago i want to say uh finishing a
reaction for the movie the atom project
i really loved it i thought it was
wonderful wonderful and i'm a big fan of
the movie free guy as well so to come
off of filming and reaction for that and
then to log on twitter while prepping
footage
i come to find out that i'm a little
late to learning because it's now a few
hours old the freaking the director of a
movie that has just given me such a
great high like a lot of laughs a lot of
tears sean levy is directing the new
deadpool movie that's right now it's
being reported like it's it's mainly in
talks however it's one of those cases
where the in talks seems pretty much
like ah it's pretty much confirmed this
is something that's been rumored for a
while because of his work on free guys
relationship with ryan reynolds and i am
just so jazzed about it i am so pumped
about it i really am i'm so freaking
excited i feel like he is perfect
absolutely perfect to do a deadpool
movie and when you look at like the
common traits of movies like the adam
project and free guy brought together
not only does he work really well with
ryan reynolds comedy style but he's also
really great at bringing the wonder he's
really great at bringing the heart and
visually he's a fantastic director and
he also knows how to capture action
scenes as well i'm not gonna say that
this will be like the best deadpool
movie
however i could see it being the best
deadpool movie because unlike the first
two deadpool films which were tim miller
and david leach that was the first time
ryan reynolds was working with those
directors and this is different this
would be ryan reynolds third film
working with sean levy the kind of
rapport the kind of dynamics that have
been established with these two that's
so important for director actor
relationship when crafting one of these
films together and ryan reynolds is such
a heavily involved producer clearly
their work and relationship is really
strong i personally think in terms of
like the ryan reynolds vehicles free guy
in the atom project are two of his
absolute best and the fact that sean
levy is now coming on board to do this
just has me super excited because i do
think he is the perfect director for
deadpool 3. because he's done more than
free guy and at a project he's one of
the most active producers on stranger
things he's directed some of the most
prominent episodes he's done real steel
on top of real steel he was doing an
interview recently with brandon davis
you know he was asked about hugh jackman
and ryan reynolds coming together i feel
like if there's anyone who could finally
make that wish come true i know it's a
long shot anytime we talk about hugh
jackman returning to the mcu for
anything it sounds like a long shot
however it's always seemed like you know
p jackman has been tempted to dip his
toe in that water again for ryan
reynolds they're clearly buddies and he
did make a cameo granted he was masked
but he did make a cameo in the movie
free guy and obviously sean levy
directed hugh jackman in real steel so
the combination of like kevin feige
marvel sean levy ryan reynolds trying to
get hugh jackman to make an appearance
in deadpool 3. this actually seems like
a true possibility he was saying he
wants to team them up in like a big fat
bromance sandwich of a movie and not
only that he seems enthusiastic
passionate and more importantly
determined determined to get it done
i mean
i don't know about you guys but this is
the most excited i've been for deadpool
3 thus far not only is he coming to the
mcu
this ah i can't wait i can't wait i just
want to come in really quick and share
the excitement with you all but what do
you guys think about this announcement
leave your thoughts down below catch you
guys soon and wish john the best in the
comments down below
[Music]